alors martin bureau christian dufour que
l'on accueille au pagne beau panel avec
plaisir josé et est en route
le le fils est en route
bonjour à vous deux christian petit mot
sur l'élection de john dryden ce que ça
voudra dire aussi pour les relations
futures avec le canada entre autres
je vous laisse aller c'est un retour à
la tradition sur le plan formel c'est
révélateur que le premier téléphone que
britten donner un chef d'état étranger
sitôt après liste du canada mais pour le
reste tout reste à trouver une ambition
d'aider des belles paroles
moi je dois dire que c'est ainsi ce à
quoi je m'intéresse encore bruce et rome
pour être franc je ne savais pas
commettre l'erreur que les sondes avait
beaucoup d'analystes ont commis ces
derniers mois ces dernières années en
suisse estime entre hommes 30 pétanque
horloge que je convertis en janvier il
va co présider ce jusqu'au 21 janvier il
peut faire encore beaucoup de trouble
pas que c'est lui qui est président en
exercice je comprends que byden pour
beaucoup de gens sont très contents
parce que trop et il faut le dire mais
reste que le cinglé représente quelque
chose de puissant qui laisse à baida est
encore love interroge non non vous avez
raison ne l'oublient payet président
jusqu'aux fêtes 20 janvier à midi pour
être est exact mais joe biden arrive le
21 et a déjà fait sa liste de décret
présidentiel retour des etats unis dans
le traité de paris retour dans
l'organisation mondiale de la santé etc
donc il là il annonce ses couleurs mais
il ne peut qu annoncé ses couleurs
monsieur bart hayden parce qu'il n'est
pas président mais martin
commentaire sur cette fin de semaine
quand même on le sentait quand même dans
le point de presse du premier ministre
trudeau qui est retenu un peu son
souffle et qui faisait attention il
choisit ses mots en sachant très bien
que monsieur trump est encore là pour
deux mois
pour ce qui est de l'arrivée de monsieur
by donne
évidemment au gouvernement du québec on
le sent aussi à ottawa puis aussi chez
les entrepreneurs les organisations qui
représente les entreprises c'est on
pousse un certain soupir de soulagement
pas parce que ça va être plus facile on
s'attend à ce que le commerce demeure
encore assez difficile les démocrates
sont reconnus pour être protectionniste
le buy american act monsieur byden
investira davantage et c'est une
préoccupation en fait on a entendu
beaucoup monsieur legault parler du buy
american act est exprimée lors que
c'était finalement un écueil dans l'eure
dans la relation avec les états unis
mais le ton sera plus léger la
diplomatie reprend ses droits
l'insultent on va passer à un autre
chacun complice julie c'est plus de
prévisibilité puis aussi la possibilité
pour
les autant les gouvernements que les
entreprises d'avoir voix au chapitre les
alumineries ici sont fait imposer des
tarifs important du jour au lendemain
sans appel
alors là on va pouvoir est un très très
bien oui permettez je trouve qu'avec
monsieur bagdad dans un premier temps
évidemment on va tenter de revenir comme
avant
sortir du cauchemar 30 retour à une
certaine tradition mais aussi à monsieur
maiden va être capable de renouveler un
peu la politique américaine dans un
contexte de la boîte allemande sera et
un point moi qui m'a quand même frappé
aujourd'hui si je suis au compte rendu
dans la presse du coup de téléphone
entre monsieur madame et monsieur
trudeau mais je dois dire qu'ils
auraient parlé entre autres choses du
racisme à l'égard des droits et moi ça
m'a beaucoup troublé parce que monsieur
trudeau sûrement pas parler de la
situation des noirs aux états unis donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut une analogie
entre le racisme à l'égard des noirs au
canada et aux états unis
je suis franchement aberrants et ça
confirme une américanisation de plus en
plus inquiétante de nos discours
politique au québec et au canada qui est
évidemment accentué par l'intérêt énorme
que tout le monde portait à la
télévision on va écouter monsieur
trudeau un donc sûr je baille donne sur
son appel sur le processus on écoute
d'abord nous faisons confiance dans le
processus électoral américain et j'étais
contente félicité le président élu
baden en fin de semaine nous allons
continuer de travailler avec
l'administration actuelle jusqu'en fin
janvier et suite à ça on va travailler
avec le nouvelle administration
évidemment ce sera mon troisième
président américain je pense que tout au
fil des années on a démontré notre
capacité et notre en phase sur d'être là
pour défendre les intérêts des canadiens
autrement dit ce qu'ils disent si j'ai
pas disjoncter avec jean m'a gêné je
suis prêt à tout il ya des choses
intéressantes comme monsieur trudeau et
monsieur bail d'une centaine sur le la
crise climatique l'urgence de cette
question là en même temps ce qui découle
de ça c'est que monsieur bart hayden va
dire au revoir à qui sert d'exemple le
pipeline qui doit amener du pétrole vers
l'est
vers le sud américain et là il voit donc
recevoir de la colère christian de
l'ouest la tulle alors c'est pas facile
de gouverner sans contradiction c'est
évident puis je pense que dans ce
premier test le plus normal par contre
ce phénomène un peu exceptionnelle qui
était trop quelle cruche et beaucoup de
gens fait un don d'un grand contentement
et grands bonheurs dans l'élection de
schilb hayden laisse quand on tombe à
terre sur le plancher des vaches
on réalise que la marge de manoeuvre de
monsieur limites et surtout qu'ils
savent être le sénat on veut savoir en
janvier
est ce que les républicains vont temps
contrôle du sénat s'il fallait que tu es
républicains contrôlent le sénat la
chambre des représentants bush voilà la
marge de manoeuvre de monsieur votre
maître magnette ministre et s'ils ne
boudons pas quand même le plaisir de
beaucoup de personnes dont voilà le
phénomène de 30 par an faites au niveau
symbolique n'est plus là bon maintenant
la filière verte est intéressant parce
qu'on parle d'eux qu'ils tombent mais on
peut parler aussi au québec deux des
rapports avec les américains parce que
on sait que le gouvernement veut vendre
de l'électricité beaucoup aux états unis
qu'ils font surtout à faire avec les
états mais le gouvernement fédéral mais
quand même quelques balises et y avait
eu un enjeu avec obama avec les
différents gouvernements autant libéral
que péquistes sur cette question là
parce que obama ne reconnaissait pas
comme une énergie renouvelable la grande
hydraulique
c'est à dire la grande hydraulique c'est
l'électricité qui provient des grands
barrages comme la romaine et ça ça va
être un gros enjeu pour le gouvernement
plusieurs le gouvernement marois de
faire accepter ça ou différents états
évidemment on ne parle plus tellement
des balises environnementales aux états
unis depuis quatre ans mais là ça
pourrait revenir ça dans les dents le
discours américain très bien christian
j'avais dit il ne faut pas bouder notre
plaisir l'autre sujet qui inspire cette
remarque c'est certainement l'avancé de
file avec son vaccin pourrait être
disponible
en début d'année et enfin un feu qui
annonce des résultats de 90 % de succès
à voir on met tous les bémols mais quand
même puis docteur le spécialiste à
québec nous disait c'est une grosse
journée quand même une grosse nouvelle
christian c'est ce qu'on attend depuis
des mois et des mois et ça s'est fait de
manière extrêmement rapide mais si
jamais il ya un vaccin prometteur ça
vient de changer la donne
fondamentalement au oui ça a l'air
sérieux je pense qu'il faut prier un
manche le sens religieux moi quand je
retiens une nouvelle comme ça parce que
sinon on est enlisé dans une crise dont
on ne sait pas comment se dépêtrer avec
évidemment des dommages sanitaires mais
des dommages sociaux je pense que ledit
économiques psychologiques énormes
donc si on peut avoir le vaccin monju
que ce serait mauvais pour beaucoup trop
rêver mais je pense qu'on en parlait
parce que sinon ça devient extrêmement
anxiogène et déprimant on le dit on le
redit l'hiver arrive les gens sont
tannés les gens sont déprimés puis que
si on se limite à juste commenté des
statistiques qui nous viennent de la
santé publique et du gouvernement il
faut le faire ne faut pas se limiter à
ça parce que sinon ça on s'en sortir au
poste comme si on donne l'impression les
gens les gens des fonds dans l'épaisseur
on dit là dedans tu sois jamais mais
qu'il faut s'habituer à ce très bien mon
mari monsieur trudeau sur le vaccin
je rappelle que le canada a commandé 20
millions de doses de ce vaccin
il ya d'autres candidats vaccins qui
sont à la corse qui vont arriver on le
souhaite le plus rapidement possible on
écoute le premier ministre on s'attend à
ce que ça arrive normalement dans les
trois premiers mois de 2000 21
évidemment on va commencer avec des des
populations prioritaires pour la
vaccination mais on devra en avoir de
plus en plus au fil des mois y compris
avec d'autres potentiels candidats
vaccins
alors martine damas entre-temps faut
continuer à gérer
et d'ailleurs c'est demain qu'arrive à
échéance les deux semaines de réflexion
annoncé par monsieur legault sont va
réduire un peu la pression dans les
zones rouges pour les restaurants à
montréal c'est la demande la santé
publique
je pense pas que les aiguille vont
bouger demain martine un nom je pense
pas cc c'est difficile c'est plus
difficile en fait que ce que le
gouvernement aurait souhaité pense que
la phrase clé du point de presse de
monsieur du ministre dubé aujourd'hui
c'était ça risque d'empirer avant de
s'améliorer alors on espérait pouvoir
changer d'ère un peu cette semaine il ya
un mini budget qui s'en vient je dis on
va parler de relance économique
on espérait aussi pouvoir lever
certaines consignes monsieur le guen
même ouvert la semaine dernière en dix
ans les jeunes qui vivent chez leurs
parents
j'aimerais ça qu'il puisse recevoir au
moins un ami de temps en temps pour
sortir un peu de leur famille et si loin
des clercs l'oif demain il peut il ya
des choses peuvent changer parce que les
décisions se prennent jusqu'à la toute
dernière minute alors je veux pas trop
m'avancer là dessus mais on réfléchit à
différentes de possibilités et le point
de presse va probablement avoir lieu à
13h et comme sébastien bovet nous disait
dans la salle de nouvelles quand c'est à
13h généralement c'est statu quo et
quand il ya des grosses nouvelles c'est
à 17,10 que l'agent je décode décret
wind christian oui on reprochait
monsieur legault cet été d'avoir des
confits d'être trop vite d'avoir ensuite
rétabli un semblant de vie normale trop
vite il pendant le danger que monsieur
legault en fait soit trop prudent dans
la période actuelle en fait veuille pas
prendre de risque moi je cache pas quant
à moi j'espère que les cinémas les
théâtres et restaurants ou de chagrin
quand on regarde ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays en fait la coved et
partout mais les gérer de façon
différente selon les sociétés peut aussi
selon le temps parce que certains pays
qui dans le vide a été très bon on m'a
donné par ensuite ça empire mais font
d'opter c'est que il ya beaucoup de
sociétés en fait où les restaurants les
cinémas et les théâtres sont restés
ouverts et pourquoi
là dessus parce que je pense que c'est
une soupape très importante pour le
moral de la population ce symbole de
joie de vivre et je pense des québécois
je parle juste pour moi même le docteur
qui seraient pas d'accord avec vous ça
vous attendez depuis le début là dessus
elle est d'accord parce qu'ils ont
recommandé je le rappelle aux gens la
santé publique de montréal qu'on ouvre
les restaurants les musées les cinémas
etc
les rudes j'aime également parce que on
voit plateau à montréal mais sur la
gauche vous le soulignez va être plus
prudent que moi
on lui a reproché de ne pas avoir été
assez prudent martin c'est ça l'idée
aussi la wii les experts pensent que
novembre votre critique qui on devra
s'habituer
et si vous avez lu ça vous a peut-être
passer sous le nez samedi à cause de la
victoire de monsieur by donne mais
monsieur legault a écrit une lettre
ouverte dans les différents médias pour
redonner un peu d'espoir est en fait
qu'on comprend c'est qu'on veut protéger
une noël
alors il risque de se garder la vie
c'est serré pour au moins un an avant
très bien merci beaucoup à vous de juger
désolé josé je pense que la ligne ne
fonctionne pas je pense la ligue ne
fonctionnait pas alors on va se
retrouver demain merci beaucoup puis je
voulais vous pas n'a pas le temps il va
il y avait un petit vidéo très très coté
promesse de mais je vous montre ça au
revoir